we are just having the time of our lives
and we never expected that
this late in our lives so we're just
trying to savor every
every moment together blake shelton and
gwen stefani
are married my god who wouldn't want to
be married to gwen stefani
the couple began dating in 2015 and they
got engaged in october of last year
so at this point in our relationship
we're always looking for
what's the next thing that we haven't
accomplished yet
after blake popped the question gwen
posted this sparkly pic of her
engagement ring to instagram
she wrote yes please and in june the
singer shared these moments from her
bridal shower
i got kidnapped by my family
to celebrate
[Music]
i'm getting married during blake's
appearance on the tonight show in may
he did reveal the 80s inspired song they
chose for their first
dance it's if you leave
from the pretty and pink soundtrack we
both love the song
we're both fans of the 80s why not
throughout the pandemic blake and gwen
shared many of their happy moments spent
at home
with blake spending tons of time with
gwen's three children that she shares
with ex
gavin rossdale how would you say gwen
makes you a better man
oh my god i don't i can't remember
i don't want to remember what i was like
before
gwen actually if that answers your
question many were shocked to find out
that the country crooner and the no
doubt singer were an item
blake was one of the original judges on
the voice upon its debut in 2011
with gwen securing a judge's chair of
her own three years later for season
seven
when did you know gwen was the one for
you
uh it didn't take long you know i had
known gwen
from working with her on the voice the
first season that she worked there but i
didn't really
know her i was literally about like i
know you it's like oh how you doing it's
good to see you again you know
in 2015 gwen and gavin went their
separate ways after 13 years of marriage
and that same year blake and fellow
country star miranda lambert split up
following
four years of marriage and then by the
time the second
time she came around you know our both
of our lives had basically
fallen completely apart and
and little did we know it happened to
both of us at the same time
and we bonded over that following
speculation of their rumored romance
e.t confirmed that blake and gwen were
an official item in november 2015.
you know he's like my bestie in the
years since they've shared their love
story with e.t
it's hard to believe that i'm back at
the grammys but
not just that but with blake shelton
that's like my favorite human being i
get to do this
did you hear that did you get that did
you report that everybody you know
she's never not been supportive or a
cheerleader
or just uh just the most encouraging
person i've ever had in my life
[Music]
you